ضود الفعل حول ما حدث الرئيس الاسرائيلي
يتحدث عن صباح صعب على التحمل في حرب لا
يوجد اعدل منها اخبرنا عن ابرز ردود الفعل
حتى الان حول ما
حدث الاسرائيليون وعلى كافه المستويات من
الناطق العسكري الى الرئيس الاسرائيلي الى
وسائطه الاعلاميه والعسكريه تصف ما جرى
بانه كارثه وانه اصعب ايام القتال منذ ان
بداتي الاسرائيلي اجتياحه البري لقطاع غزه
في ال 26 من اكتوبر الماضي ما جرى حسب ما
المعلومات المتوفره هو ان القتلى في الجيش
الاسرائيلي الذين سقطوا خلال ال 24 ساعه
الاخيره كان جلهم هو في مبنيين في منطقه
مخيم المغازي في الوسطى في المحافظه
الوسطى من قطاع غزه وهو مخيم ايضا قريب من
منطقه الحدود وكانت هناك قوات من من
الهندسه ومن الاحتياط تقوم بتفخيخ هما
وبعد تقريبا ان اوشكت على اتمام عمليات
التفخيخ لنس فهما اطلقت قذائف او صواريخ
الار بي جي وادت الى الى اختراقه وانفجار
عمليه التفخيخ مما ادى الى مقتل كل واصا
وجرح كل من كان متواجد داخل المبين
المبنيين هذا نحو الرابعه بالتوقيت المحلي
من عصر يوم امس وامتدت عمليه محاوله تخليص
الجثث وانقاذ جرحى حتى ساعات فجر هذا
اليوم المواقع الاخرى هي كانت في منطقه
ايضا غرب خانيونس هذه المنطقه شهدت
بالاساس عمليه قصف لصاروخ استهدف قوات
داخل مبنى انهار هو الاخر وكذلك قصف دبابه
بقذيفتين فيها مجمل ما اعلنه الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن القتلى فقط و 21 خلال ال 24
ساعه او خلال تقريبا 15 ساعه الاخيره وهي
الاحداث التي شهدها هذا اليوم الذي يصفه
الاسرائيليون بانه كارثه وبانه الاقسى
والاشد في القتال مع قواتهم رغم انهم
دفعوا بقوات كبيره تصريح الرئيس
الاسرائيلي ياتي في محاوله لاعاده شيء من
الامل لدى الاسرائيليين باستمرار العمليه
البريه هو قال في صبيحه هذا اليوم المؤلم
والقاسي لابد من ان نؤكد على استمرار
الحرب حتى تحقيق الانتصار ومثل هذه
التسمع الكثيرين من الاسرائلين وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي ايضا قال هذه حرب ستحدد
مستقبل اسرائيل للعقود القادمه وسقوط
جنودنا وصيه لتحقيق اهداف
الحرب نعم هذه الردود هي جاءت لتؤكد بان
الحرب لن تتوقف بعد هذه الضربه التي
تلقتها القوات الاسرائيليه سواء في
المنطقه الوسطى من قطاع غزه او في منطقه
خانيونس
واللافت فيما جرى للاسرائيليين انفسهم ان
الضربه القويه جاءتهم بالاساس في منطقه من
المفترض انهم اتموا السيطره ع عليها او
على اجزاء كبيره منها مثل مخيم المغازي
ومنطقه الوسطى ويركزون على منطقه مخيم خان
يونس والمنطقه الغربيه من خان يونس لذلك
تصريحات سواء وزير الدفاع او الرئيس
الاسرائيلي وما قاله ايضا الناطق باسم
الجيش وما سنسمع على مدار هذا اليوم
جميعها ستؤكد على الاصرار في استمرار
القتال والحرب والان هو ال اصبحت الامور
على مفترق طرق بخصوص ما هي استراتيجيه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وجيشها بخصوص رفح
ومحور فيلادلفيا مجتمعه تاتي في مجملها
ايضا لتؤكد ان الحرب ثمن باهظ وهم يتحدثون
ايضا عن انهم الحقوا خسائر فادحه في
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وانهم قتلوا اكثر من
100 من مدرها وقادتها سواء في منطقه
خانيونس او منطقه غرب خانيونس او مخيم
خانيونس لذلك التصريحات الوارده وردود
الفعل الاوليه حتى الان على المستوى
الرسمي وكذلك ما ينقله المراسلون
العسكريون عن الجيش وعن والمراسلون
السياسيون عن القيادات السياسيه جميعها
تدفع باتجاه ان الحرب ستستمر رغم ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي تلقى ضربه قاسيه من المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وهو ما رفع هذا الع عدد من
القتلى في الجيش الاسرائيلي رفع مجمل عدد
قتلى الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ عمليه طوفان
الاقصى وبدايه الحرب على غزه التي تدخل
يومها 109 الى
556 قتيلا بين ضابط وجدي ورفع عدد قتلى
الجيش الاسرائيلي من الضباط والجنود منذ
بدايه اياحه وحربه البريه على قطاع غزه في
السا من اكتوبر الى
226 ضابطا وجنديا قتيلا هذه الاعداد التي
تتزايد باضطراد رغم انه يدفع بقوات اضافيه
وخلال الايام الماضيه دفع بارت دبابات الى
داخل القطاع رغم انه يجري اعاده انتشار
بين الحين والاخر بعد ثلاثه نحو اربعه نحن
نقترب من نهايه الشهر الرابع من هذه الحرب
تقريبا ويتحدث الاسرائيليون عن انها قد
تستمر الى عام او اكثر الان السؤال الكبير
المطروح اسرائيليا هو ماذا بشان منطقه رفح
ومحور فلادلفيا
تمكن من السيطره على منطقه خانيونس ونحن
نرى انه حتى الان على المنطقه الوسطى في
قطاع غزه لم يتم سيطرته وتلقى الضربه
القويه فيها تحديدا وهذه الاح الاحداث
التي وقعت خلال الساعات 20 او 24 الاخيره
وتحديدا تفجير المبنيين كل منهما من
طابقين بقوات من الهندسه والاحتياط ووجود
عدد كبير من الضباط وقعت في منطقه المغازي
تحديدا وان الضربات الاخرى كانت في منطقه
خانيونس وتحديدا غرب خانيونس فماذا سيفعل
تجاه منطقه رفح خاصه وانها مقتضى
بالنازحين
الفلسطينيين ومساله معبر رو محور فلا دلفي
او ه الحدود بين بين مصر وفلسطين وجنوبي
قطاع غزه هي مساله لها تداعيات سياسيه قد
تكون من هنا ما جرى حاليا يوصل اسرائيليا
على كافه المستويات بانه اصعب ايام القتال
منذ ان بدا الاجتياح البري الاسرائيلي
لقطاع غزه ويوصف ما نتيجته بانها كارثيه
بمعنى ان مقتل هذا العدد الكبير من الجنود
والضباط 21 في خلال ساعات قليله ومواجهه
الجيش الاسرائيلي صعوبات جمه في محاوله
تخليص الجثث وتخليص الجرحى يشير الى ان
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تنزل او توجع الجيش
الاسرائيلي عندما تنصب له الكمائن كما جرى
في منطقه المغازي على وجه الخصوص وهذا
يؤشر الى ان الحرب هذه ما زالت نهايتها
بعيده جدا وان ما يدور عن
حديث حول صفقات تبادل او ان تطرح اسرائيل
ترحيل قاده حماس والمقاومه من قطاع غزه
الى خارج القطاع هي تبدو اضغاث احلام حتى
الان بالنسبه للاسرائيليين انفسهم ويبدو
اننا امام ايام قتال ستكون ضاريه مقبله
تحديدا في منطقه خان يونس ومخيم خان يونس
الذين دفعوا اليه بسبع كتائب من قوات
مشتركه من الهندسه والكوماندوز وسلاح
اليابسه وغير ذلك مع اسناد مدفعي واسناد
جوي وفق البيانات الرسميه الاسرائيليه
يبدو انه ايضا سيكون ميدان قتال ضار جدا
خاصه وان الاسرائيليين يعتق يقدون بانه
قلب معقل كتائب القسام وقياده القسام وان
معظم المحتجزين الاسرائيلي ربما يكون
محتجزين داخل انفاق في هذه المنطقه وان
القياده العليا للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
ولكتاب القسام تتواجد ايضا في هذه المنطقه
وواضح بان ما يجري هو صراع بين النخب
النخبه في قوات القسام والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه وايضا وحدات النخبه في الجيش
الا اسرائيلي الجيش الاسرائيلي الى معركه
خانيونس تحديدا كان قد دفع خلال الاسبوعين
الاخيرين بوحدات من قوات النخبه شلدا
التابعه لسلاح الجو وسياره متكال او دوريه
رئاسه الاركان
والمخصصه عاده من ضباط مدربين للقيام
بعمليات خلف الحدود وكذلك شيته 13 وهي
وحده النخبه في سلاح الجو هذه دفع بها الى
هذه المعارك مع قوات بريه وقوات من المدر
واسناد جوي وايضا مدفعي